so Jean Jacques but not from
France but from Brazil
so let's try this strange move here again
with the idea of ​​coming here in Slavic
exchange, it
worked, but he knows a
little bit here,
that's
not the most powerful opening
but not quite either  without an idea,
for example, this is a bit
dangerous for Black
on B5, I can take it now
and now it's unpleasant here. It's
tied up here,
so it works: this is
A6,
yes, as you can see, Slavic exchange can
also be dangerous,
well, there is one  Inaccuracy is enough to make
E6 a bit strange,
actually, where he looks completely normal,
but then black has to
play precisely because he hasn't done so
and then it happens really quickly